what mistakes to the writers make in
this episode I'll get this in say the
rise make any mistakes they're gray I
think obviously be be wise I mean
they're they're they're they're amazing
what do you think I really like the way
they write dialogue I do I don't have
any I don't have any real specific
dialogue problems I just think that Rob
is the oldest son shouldn't have had
something to do mm-hmm
we don't learn anything about him at all
yeah I think going back to what I said
earlier I think just I know I know why
the characters whether it's physical
action exposition or dialogue exposition
I feel you know Jamie is just a little
on the nose you know I feel like I'm
bumping into him and challenging him and
a duel at a tournament I mean I get it I
know why we need it but I would have
liked to see them develop the characters
just just a little less on the nose
obviously Arya's the tomboy you know
maybe just a little less on the note not
vague at all no specific obviously but
but just a little less like princess
tomboy bad guy Evil Queen they present a
strong dichotomy there yeah the even
thing I feel like that's done with a
sole purpose of subverting those
characters I feel like that's one of the
biggest themes of Game of Thrones
averting what you've come from you know
each of the characters if you watch them
now versus where they are currently
almost all of them have completely
subverted their their own expectations
but I mean I mean like yeah absolutely
that's true but you know they I guess
they stay on the same the same course
essentially you know - Arya goes off and
is at one point clearly mistaken for
being a boy you know it's like it's
really on the nose and there should have
a maybe a little bit more of a complex
relationship between Jaime Lannister and
they did fight on the same side of the
war
yeah and together yeah so I don't think
it would it it was so just like we'd
love to see you down at King's Landing
at the dick the next joust yeah I'm
saying they didn't talk about like like
a war story didn't they like so how
things been those are some mutual
respect because it's so good about
complicated relationships and also
there's nothing between Catelyn Stark
and Cersei hardly at all hardly like
just one line during dinner but that's
got to be interesting they have sort of
similar lives they're both married two
parallel two to two men that know each
other for a long time there should be
some history there like there's some
gossip you know anything at all but they
don't they hardly say anything to each
other yeah they did hold back on showing
their relationship I would I will say
that I just thought about that they did
hold back on their relationship a little
bit I kind of wanted to see more of it
not not even just their relationship but
the the strength of both women in one
place because both are very strong and
both have their petty issues now to put
them sitting next to each other in the
same room I would love to see some
sparks fly with their with their you
know sometimes when you're the same side
of sandpaper rubbing against each other
and I feel like that's them they're the
same side of sandpaper and they're just
I wouldn't see them I know illyrio who's
uh sheltering viserys and danerys over
in Pentos yeah we don't find out
anything about him he appeared to be an
important character in retrospect and
now I can understand why they didn't
show that much about him because it's
really all about viserys and danerys
right over there but how did they get
over there why did they go there who is
he who and why is he protecting them and
sheltering they explain a lot of these
things throughout the episode yeah of
course they do but but you know picking
a part of a pilot picking are just like
this is one episode what they could show
yeah yeah sometimes you wonder like if I
wrote this and handle it myself
what would they say what'd they say
Jorah Mormont just approaches Daenerys
out of nowhere and I don't know who's
more monsaert
I wasn't opening credits many of them
already right and I don't know what how
did he come to fight with the Dothraki
why would they accept him what's he
doing over here
is this like white guy with armor are
doing just all of a sudden at this
wedding how do you get invited to the
wedding
what's he doing over here yeah and why
did why did uncle Benjy let's get
allowed to leave the wall for a bit to
go to this party the party director's
cut they execute Benjamin yeah that's
some exposition with the Benjen Ned
Stark conversation right there was a
little bit of unrealistic dialogue there
I forgot exactly what he said to him but
he's like I can't believe my brother
might be the hand of the king soon yeah
that was redundant well I just wanted to
show that they were brothers but we are
yeah and and I really think that he had
the obligation that he had the
opportunity to turn this down Mike are
you allowed to do that I thank you
anyway for coming I know you came a
month all the way up here and I didn't
even know I was gonna take the job right
I want to thank you for reaching out and
we'll be in touch down the line if any
other opportunities go you could turn
this down if you want to and it was like
that's the king okay no I don't think
we're allowed to turn it down yeah you
know Assad she knew he was gonna take
that oh yeah yeah interesting
interesting
in there so yeah you're gonna do how
interesting how Catelyn knows like this
this has to happen and she she be
whether she's okay with it or not she
allows it to happen and then we look at
Sarah see who really does her best to
turn the head of that king you know she
where Callen is just like okay all right
and Pharisees like I will make sure that
he does what I say you know what I mean
yeah and so she's watching her husband
openly make out with other women in a
party register any sort of reaction she
doesn't like look away with disgust or
returned wine and drink it as exposition
but but she you know I guess they're one
of the show that this is just
commonplace for him cause he already
says he wants to hold his way to an
early gray I think I just thought of one
other thing writing I would have done
when I heard Meister Lewin for the first
time I was like are they saying mister
in a different way what's a Meister who
is this guy is it like a code name for
uncle cuz every now and then when you
hear a word you know like wildling or
meister and you don't know what that is
i would have said you could have had a
little conversation about you know so
how long has your my sister been here
you know like we didn't know that they
trained at the city you know at the
citadel and every single town has one
all the kingdoms do so I didn't know
what my student loves when I first heard
it again we learn all these things we do
learn them all but more lines of
thinking of like again what would my
notes be final for somebody what
Sagmeister
Brian you have to explain what a Meister
is in your pilot I don't have a
10-episode order so you know you don't
have that luxury lose anything is
necessary that they explain all these
things in a pilot episode no no but
there's little things that stick in your
mind that you're wondering about how
some of those things are really healthy
like White Walkers yeah I don't know but
I know that we're gonna revisit that and
the other things you just have to pick
up in context like yeah somebody says
what and they explain this once he's
like what's your sigil and it's like
what the emblem the banner mitten that's
later explained that Ned is sitting on
the throne for Robert while he's right
about hunting or something but some of
the things are not explained right away
yeah I have no idea what a Meister is
until later on but again there's so much
information to meter out you have to
wonder how much of it is important how
much how much of it is right now yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the skill of
writing a pilot is how much can we
explain and should we explain and do we
explain right now
yeah to hook a buyer to hook an
executive to hook and network to hook an
audience most importantly right and and
I again we're being super nit picky but
really they think they nailed it with
with it they made
they didn't know this entire thing that
was a perfect pilot to be honest it was
a great pilot it's a fun one I wouldn't
say perfect I would say fun as close as
perfectly the I've ever seen there's
some shows I don't know if I should talk
about right and I'll just say this I
really like watching that pair of pants
fall from the sky that's all I'm gonna
say no I'm lost
it's Breaking Bad that's great pilot
that's that's the other real Titan of
our birth time rate pilot violent yeah
not only who's better than this one and
I love it buy apples and oranges yeah
yeah yeah you know I think about the
subject matter yeah really to compare
this to
it's true but little tiny details here
and there about stuff that could be
explained sure but again yeah now that I
think about my second guess myself
because my Styria is not there's only so
much real estate on the page right like
it was crammed in you know a few yeah
Meister like me has been in your family
for all those years time to Winterfell
maybe maybe that's what maybe that's why
they made brand the eyes for the
audience in this episode because as
we're seeing it through a ten-year-old
it that we're just seeing what a 10 year
olds gonna see it what's most important
to a 10 year old you know and maybe
that's what it is
I'm glad they actually kept out a couple
details in this because I feel like that
it helps I think it helps build the
world like what everything the whole
Meister thing all that I feel like
knowing that those things exist you know
I feel like even if you know even if you
don't know that they're gonna explain
some of those minor details I find the
fact that they exist help you understand
that this is an entire world so it
immerse that I'm better yeah and I feel
like had they gone into detail with some
other things it would have negatively
impacted the pilot also it's really
different when you know you have ten
episodes to shoot you can postpone stuff
yeah when you know you're gonna be on a
you know HBO with that many viewers you
know that you have time it's different
when you're just writing a pilot as a
right exam
and it all has to be is the promise was
so much more and also work as a
self-contained story so some of these
things don't apply yeah absolutely
absolutely that's a big one
as a surprise factory I mean pick one
yeah the body is the body parts
disappearing and the partisan enterprise
the the incestuous relationship is a
huge surprise that was really gross at
the beginning you know but Ned's just
hanging out with his family and
someone's like Ned you gotta go
decapitate this guy Oh
bring the 10 year old yeah I think
there's the fact that there was those
creatures have been dead for thousands
of years and ever no one believes in
them that was a surprise like that adds
a level of impact and like the amount of
impact I thought about that like they
didn't believe in these things but they
exist and now you're kind of aware of
the ignorance of these characters no
they believed it was just like if I were
to say dude I just saw a Tyrannosaurus
Rex outside oh okay they don't believe
the big exist anymore because of that
you kind of put into this awareness of
their ignorance as a scare because
that's a community almost yeah but
that's what makes a wild thing more I
think the content itself is a surprise
as far as like watching this young lady
get raped like watching it it's like
right there watching how and I think
that's why this show so great because it
pushed so many boundaries and and though
it is HBO it's still they still allow a
lot of different things to to occur and
you know of this this young that this
this this war van character who is now
being ransacked by four prostitutes
it's like this is what this is gonna be
it's like it's like here's here's the
bar for television here's you know like
other shows and then here is Game of
Thrones and this is where this is the
bar we're starting at and it only just
gets crazier there's a filter yeah they
pay they pay a lot of respect to the
subject matter and the time period if
you can yeah
just read it with the way they show
things they're very unapologetic
absolutely I think it's I think it's
because of that I can appreciate
I can appreciate all the little actions
a little more you know the the rape
that's that was terrible that's like
very hard to watch
yeah the fact that they did it before I
was saying and I feel like because the
deep the brutality has led to the
characters themselves even though it's
not a character based thing really the
brutality and the I just the misogyny of
the entire series yeah I think it adds
layer to the characters as they grow the
profound cruelty and passion of the
characters you know at the beginning the
saris just says to Daenerys I need you
to be perfect today and you'll think oh
maybe they have a sweet relationship
then he walks over to her and it's just
like I would let every single one of
those 40,000 men have sex with you and
their horses to get this and you're just
like whoa unbelievable cruelty and the
passionate the passion of the characters
is shocking you have you have the body
of a woman now and then he he grazes her
body and it's just like vomit you know
that's one of them crazy things but I
may be off with this a little bit I can
tell me if I am but I feel like the
reason why people resonate with this
show on such a heavy levels because I
think that in one way or another as
people we exude that that that very
savage mentality I feel like I hope I
don't I think that the exhilaration we
get from this show of the exact same
exhilaration we go when we saw the Dark
Knight and Heath Ledger's performance
hmm you know that that did that that
savagery I think that that all is inside
of us and I think that's I think we
actually like it bracelet tools to some
extent you know one watching a horror
film as pleasurable almost in a sadistic
way and I I think that's why we love it
so much to be honest maybe I'm off there
but I'm just assessing people and why
they love these cares so much and the
content to be nice people
yeah I feel like I feel like that's the
sort of like universal thing that exists
because there's so why we like these
totally unlikable characters you know
when you meet Matt and Jamie they seem
like normal nights you know they've
killed some people and then you go and
you meet like the mountain and you've
you know stuff that he's done you know
crushing people's heads it just keeps
going further and further you like all
right I've had to have met the sickest
character I was watching with my
roommate she just kept saying it gets
worse and I said you know Littlefinger's
bad and then he gets worse and he gets
worse and they starts kissing Sansa and
then you're like all right you get your
lips off of her you get your lips off of
her yeah we were talking about surprises
before I mean the end of the first
season is built on you know the surprise
heard round the world
these characters are even like the
normal ones you like Roose Bolton
doesn't seem like that you see him turn
and then you're like okay well the
mountain Roose there's no one where so
then you see Ramsay Bolton you just it
just shocks you someone worse than
Ramsay aside from the White Walkers
mountain you think worse than Ramsay
well remember what the mountain did to
oberyn's sister and children right right
but we weren't there to experience that
we've done true hold that oh you mean in
terms of what you've seen like what
we've seen aside from the White Walkers
who is worse than Ramsay drogon awesome
thing that I noticed when he when she
opened up the cast the eggs yeah
Dragon's egg we
no way no if that wasn't a galaxy then
they left it in there because if you're
watching that it was accidental you you
could just be like we'll leave that in
okay I didn't even notice that
what really quickly what we're the
moments that like as far as the red
wedding the purple wedding you know
these big big striking moments John
Johnson's death and then rebirth come on
what were the big ones like ensuring
that was I was literally I wish I had a
video camera I was pacing back and forth
25 feet away like in like three feet and
I was like no just like all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna stop watching this show
if this starts don't make a comeback and
that's why I'm saying or some episodes I
just I was like I don't know if I can
okay yeah that was probably the best one
of the best fight scenes I've seen in a
while dude that one made me so happy
when when Ramsay kills the youngest
stark but she was like missing missing
the three shot and then hitting with the
fourth I was like oh god finally comes
up and they torched the field Jamie
comes back to King's Landing covered in
ash I think and he's like you don't
understand she's like we can buy more
people he's like I think the biggest one
for me aside from like obviously the red
wedding which is the at most epic moment
I think is when when the white Walker
right raises the dragon from the dead
and now that was creeping in drag that
was probably one of the biggest moments
for me that had me like oh [ __ ] they're
really about to kill everybody and then
burning down the wall and it's just like
yeah when it's coming oh when it's the
winters here
see it's cold now blue fire I was like
is that I sir is that blue fire that's
all it's blue fire but do this yeah
every sale every season there's one
there's one there's one heart crunching
epicene or you just like it just like I
don't know how much more I can take
I really have to just break up we might
have gone off topic from the question
okay the strength of the story so
obviously they are incredible at world
building
I mean we're given two i'm george RR
martin who penned the books and and then
and they Betty Hoff I believe David I'm
David DB Weiss just like head of the
show and and to create such a world and
I know it's said all the time but it's
so true and to go to a million different
locations and to understand them fully
by the end of the season and to
understand the cultures right for
example up north
bastards are called snows down south
they're called sands right I mean North
those details right like that are
perfect of building those worlds like
that just unbelievable and then and then
taking the written word that grr Martin
doing row and turning it into a visual
medium and then painting you know
painting this this this blind the
painting this person of many faces right
the man of many faces and and showing
him and her or whatever he is or it is
you know and like seeing that just like
they're so good at that yeah you know
you're writing really takes to step up
when you start making characters that
have some good and some bad
yeah the first couple of scripts your
writers are one-dimensional and and
serve the story and you're just trying
to get through it but these guys do such
a good job about unbelievably complex
character and first analysis ned is just
a really good man that got really
unlucky but if you think about it more
and he just value duty a little bit too
much to farm was blind yeah and not a
Catlin you know she wasn't completely on
our own when she incorrect when she said
you know this horror has been visited in
my family because I couldn't love a
motherless son she at first glance is
just completely wholesome and then later
on it's a little bit more ambiguous and
then they do great things with Jamie
Lannister and the Hound bad
thing that they do is character arcs on
a long trip I've never seen anything
like it I've never had a character in
one season and then a lot of them watch
them getting mastered and watch the one
thing that define them get taken away
from them and having to rebuild a new
personality and completely change I
under the mentors every scene that under
the mentorship of someone you never
would expect I mean Brants heart like
you never expect her to be his mentor
Yeah right it's amazing yeah that's
never been done but most another shows
the evil guy becomes more evil yeah but
in this show it's completely definite it
changes it changes the way you yeah yeah
you think Joffrey is the baddie and then
he dies and then you see ramsey and
you're like oh there was someone worse
than him I mean crazy it's crazy because
like they make each each person's
character arc and it's wine with one
other and they grow from that from even
be on different continents
yeah even small thing like this the
small here they get into and I love how
you can grow with these characters and
no one's ever had a point of stagnation
at any point is it I said I never saw
that but you know each character seems
to grow in their own way yeah I think
that like most people hey I grew up find
a favorite character because I see
something about themselves in that
character and Daenerys you know has to
make some tough decisions she has to
decide whether or not to kill some
people who are obviously opposed to her
that she's captured you know what do you
do with prisoners of war and in this
situation if you kill them or not you
could you could have a very good
argument either way about about that
moral ambiguity yes and that's just on
top of the scope and the scale and the
special effects I know I know
well ambiguity in the long term
character arcs are like nothing you've
ever seen yeah well okay so this is a
hard question is what do they what
suffers what would I struggle with
so I feel like and again I it's probably
small story things to me throughout the
entire seven
possibly a season so far but I think
they should I think they may have should
have kept John for your life you know I
think John fishes they stayed alive I
think because because I only think that
because and I just trying to be sad in
my own way I'm always saying that
because I think that his character
pointed out one of the biggest themes of
Game of Thrones and that's power I think
that keeping him around would have mercy
thirsty represents that I think Joffrey
was that little more what young so I
think that because if you see how
quickly he can't not only did he come
into power very quickly but he was under
he's given it right so he was given
power and he had control over everything
and you get right I'm saying the theme
of power uh-huh
and how in the wrong hands it can really
be like terrible I think that Joffrey's
like the probably the best example of
that to be honest I mean do me wrong I
think search is like a pretty bad
character but I don't think she was
anywhere near the savagery of Joffrey
and had he grown up I think he would
have been much more savage than her well
they're both really cool you know when
they ran out of books and they had to
improvise
they made some questionable decisions
later on in the show
this whole manufactured drama between
Sansa and Arya and I will say what yeah
time jumps about the scale of the world
right how people can get and and also
this ridiculous plan of trying to
convince Cersei to help them or or ask
her for a truce yeah and and why would
you let Jon Snow go on a suicide mission
up north of the wall and be like listen
if I let you go north of the wall and
you get killed the whole north will
execute me yeah Publix I'm not doing it
right there was some questionable plot
decisions in the later seasons yeah if I
had to really criticize before that it's
really brutal on the good guys for years
like the good guys lose and are tortured
and are unjustly murdered for several of
the first season's do you need real
stamina to get
through analytical tea like we could
they didn't have a single victory for a
while the good guys they were just
getting battered and murdered eventually
it started to become like alright you
know enough is enough
it wasn't until season 5 where things
really started to turn hey I've been you
know since it was a lot of good people
also had a lot of misery visited upon
them you know there were bad guys that
got their comeuppance but there was a
lot of innocent people who really really
suffered but I think I think they
struggled in the season where they spent
a little too much time in Dorne and and
with the Dorne stories really not
necessary I don't know wait yeah but but
once his brother the king yeah once that
stuff that who the daughter did that was
I say that I think my opinion was League
is but of course they're coming from not
having that information at that was that
was added because a few things I've
heard I don't want to say anything
because I'm not 100 cent certain but I
know I know that kind of plot element
was just the old money
yeah I think that overall after you know
they ran out of books and they started
to they had to improvise ink that
overall they did a good job here they
did very well with how they kept the
story going or you seem that it kind of
took a radical change that was negative
I think it's sped up
I think it's sped up a bit I think last
couple seasons they started going really
fast priming a lot in getting everybody
one calling one continent right it
happened quick I think and that was just
I I that one I remember having to
suspend my disbelief a bit mmm you know
and the political intrigue died down and
that was a yeah I thought yes this
Tyrion was playing the games as a hand
of king of initially or people and
finding out her and Varys and
Littlefinger were playing politics and
they have their little birds and
everything and all of a sudden there's
not much for those characters to do they
got rid of Littlefinger but there wasn't
much for Varys to do and rounder why and
he was trying to put he was he wasn't
betrayal to Daenerys
quickly but why alive and not the other
person yeah so Tyrion is a little bit
overrated as well how did you cysteine
character how does a character that's a
strategist okay lame to see what he did
great with the Battle of the Blackwater
so what did he do that was that great
over for Daenerys he's just he did he
kind of he kind of screwed up her to her
town for for a minute there yeah he
tried to make a deal with the slavers
inside and that didn't work but that was
Ben he learned from that yeah but I
don't know it's a master strategist but
Littlefinger nothing my little finger
right that's true and I can't compare a
little thing I don't know I don't think
I know
he's smarter than little finger cuz he's
still alive yeah so Littlefinger all of
a sudden became kind of stupid you know
house up well he didn't know anything
about the Bolton's and why would he sell
Sansa to them what did he get in
exchange for that protection from the
Bolton's he was trying to know but
seriously with the Queen would be the
one to give him a lot of Winterfell so I
don't know why he would just grab Sansa
who was very valuable and just flicker
to the Bolton's to appease them what
reason did Littlefinger have to appease
Roose Bolton and why would he get just
hand Sansa over I can't wait to read the
comments cuz there's no but Varys has
kind of run out of things to do hmm I'm
ready to read it I want it I want to see
all the knowledge that didn't know I
missed a note on this Stannis he was a
great character and why is Melisandre so
bad at being like well I should get
everything wrong like what can you see
in the flames should they've done so
special keep getting it wrong like right
I looked in the flames that I'm wrong I
followed the wrong person we know your
name I mean you keep seeing the wrong
part is the Lord of Light just messing
with you like what's going on Season
eight catches on that's a good point
yeah he's coming back we'll see what
happens yeah yeah
you